okay what to do it's 806 is there a
tournament I can join
let's join the tournament where is it
tournaments let's try and redeem myself
super blitz okay I'll play the super
blitz if people want to join I'll leave
a link in the chat this is a 57 minute
long tournament I'm joining slightly
late I'll beserk anyone below 2000 how
abouts and I'll be competitive 15
minutes left
I'll try and I'll try and make a running
for first place we have a four nights no
Halloween ooh
but the Center for trick I enjoy a good
cup of Center for trick might be for him
this is a move that Larry Kauffman
recommends in the Kauffman repertory I
think it's a computer's top choice it's
supposed to give black I think a
slightly preferable position but it's
been a while since I've looked at this
guy should take there's some idea with
f5 coming up and the bishops a bit
awkward like Bishop d3 I could take
right away or maybe just afford first
probably for first yeah but this f5 move
is like it's one of the main tools to
make night before work I guess it's it's
effective against players who aren't so
familiar with this thing Bishop d7
breaking the pin and on mishima Fork
great camera quality this is the same
webcam I I always use at least streaming
from my laptop
I think the lighting is good because I'm
I'm sitting facing a window
okay whites being a little bit tricky
but maybe I can be tricky back I'm gonna
play Queen d4 looks slightly wrong cuz
there's c3 let's do it
there's a trick that if Queen h5 this
takes takes my rooks defended by my
queen and for the time being the knight
and the bishop are still hanging this
should be five I have c6 and the time
advantage is growing there's c3 Queen
takes e5 takes an ambition d6
defending my queen threatening mate and
then threatening the bishop so I don't
see any problems here oh can I extend
the right side oh I see what you mean
I'll spray g6 here
yeah let's extend this Thanks soaking
wet sigh for pointing that out
let's pre move this move there you go
should be better Wow Bishop b5
King d8 yeah white just didn't have any
time to to play c3 and now I have some
attack of the open files
I made threats bring the knight back
into play King is pretty safe on D 8 D
for dua on pass on I could just take on
d4 - oh let's do this up a lot of time
maybe f4 and go it's kind of nice to
keep the D file closed for white so my
King won't suffer now I'm just opening
up the bishop bishop by 5 does that trap
the Queen I just played this as a
natural developing move but it's it's
very close to trapping McQueen rook at
Queen f7 I guess saves white some crazy
mmm I want to go insane here sort of
this
so f3 looking for ways to just win
quickly I'm not going to repeat bring
the Knights closer to the Kings side
Vlad's thanks for subbing after you move
just attacking the Queen Queen is almost
I guess I can go back this way yeah
that's one sad Queen take a bishop I
want to bring my Knight to e2 ok that
was a fun game that's nice nice little
opening there ok
playing registration 11 let's preserve
its piggy for time to be aggressive
caro-kann let's play let's play the
hillbilly it's interesting setup
maybe f4 okay it's important to remember
that I've asserts and that I don't have
as much time as I think I do
bring the Queen back this is pleasant I
have some potential attack g4 g5 ideas
f5 is interesting just opening up lines
9h8
what's with opponents just putting their
pieces in the corner maybe this move
you're threatening mates again I just
want to go insane f6 is too insane I
mean this looks Pleasant oh I have ideas
of Queen g3 nine of six mates that could
be pretty sweet it's actually funny like
if I play Queen g3 this doesn't quite
work here wants to take on a5 let's
defend I was thinking if I play Queen g3
how does black stop knight of six it's
not an easy threat to stop let's do this
well have 22 seconds I forgot to berserk
checkmate
okay back to tournaments there's a quick
moments of panic but they were saved by
the smothered mates okay you should
probably leave the rook okay let's
beserk d4 okay let's just play let's
accept the danish free pawns everywhere
but let's give them back actually we're
playing a slightly strange line this is
still all theory I lose a queen
temporarily but then I win it back yeah
this is um I think it's a pretty well
known line you're a rookie it looks
natural I used to play this a lot like
growing up back when more people played
the Danish so White has a king side
majority I have the Queen side majority
ninety-five defends upon b6 defends the
Knights it's a nice relationship between
Knight and pawn I'll play c6 get the D
file I'll keep the bishop bishops are
important when there's pawns pawn
majorities on different flanks I
probably could have taken that now I can
take it oh I could have taken the
Knights repeats I guess not
okay mr. free nights but life is still
still nice I think I'm winning a night
how does white defend King g2 walks into
a pin
okay ooh this walks into another pin
okay doctor term in second place already
after three games hello to pass pawn
quadruple nine it's very cold outside
what's the weather what's the weather
it's 44 degrees Fahrenheit it's pretty
cold I'm used to Asian temperatures do I
play here let's play c4 try and
transpose into yeah transposing to a
panel this will be a bit more a bit more
positional than normal knight c6 Bishop
g5 looks natural yeah I was gonna say
very often black starts by developing
the Bishop to e7 so in some sense I I
want a tempo how to make use of it some
d5 idea d5 don't think works
and 95 let's play 95 but then I lose d4
I could play a 4 hmm not entirely sure
what to do here
Bishop d3 is a move I could go insane
let's go insane I'm sacking upon with
the hopes of attacking and destroying
yeah I just came back from Taiwan
weather in Taiwan was amazing it was
like 70 in the 70s every day I could
take like queen h5 yeah so I'll still
have some attack there's a rule in chess
where if your whites and you have a pawn
on e5 you should attack on the Kings
side this gaining time on the Queen and
Bishop will find a happy home on d3 I
just lose connection what just happened
I think I lost connection no okay now I
think I'm back sorry about that I think
it just kind of gave up for a moment
there I love people heard what I said
but the rule is if you have a white pawn
on e5 you should attack on the Kings
side and that's what I'm doing and it's
paying off I could have forked but this
is better
okay GG apology is fair maybe losing
connection not sure if it and like
completely died or it just lagged off of
it still in second place whoa big ty for
a second four people have actually a tie
for first technically for people with 14
points maybe I'll play one of them does
this mean joke Oh Pam and Joe cope among
cos okay let's play e5 again ooh have a
[ __ ] your counter gambit
should be fun
the dog is excited Bishop III should be
three this is some line Knight f3 and
then Queen e7 pretty sure this is like
one of the main lines I remember some
idea of like at some point playing
Bishop C one has black like we trade on
e3 and then the thread is Bishop c1 it's
like very unusual just attacking from
behind and then threatening to trap the
rook so it has to be a little bit
careful
I play Bishop c1 here Bishop c1
it's a greedy move but I think it wins
at least a pawn I mean what's gonna get
compensation but I couldn't not do it
it's just too much of a beauty the ship
belongs on c3 I guess I guess eyes rook
b3 b3 I could trade on d2 the question
is how am I going to develop and play
this move pinning a knight threatening
this that should take ste 2 so if rook
takes b7 visual takes you to I win a
piece so white escapes a pin play Bishop
a5
what else to do play Bishop C eights
mm-hmm b6 looks weakening b6 looks okay
though Bishop b5 Kim D 8
Wow so whites being aggressive f6 or h6
b h6 this is a weird position expecting
94 at some points white might start ooh
not expecting that 94 let's play Bishop
d4 is now this Knight is a bit awkward
but my bishop both bishops are awkward
for me play Bishop e3 it's a very
strange game so far
oh it's Castle so I have f5 hmm just
scared that things are about to happen
to me because White has a lot of pieces
directed at the Kings side but I think I
am threatening to take our the very
least threatening to play off 5 so
White's mites on a counter attacking
spree Bishop is very short on squares
yes I'll do this
I getting punished bishop h7 I don't
think does anything
it forces King h8 it's really scary it's
like this this feels so so fragile I
don't want to take that my knight
develop 97 so the bishop defends the
night and very soon my knight should be
defending my bishop mmm let's play this
move some idea of c4 and Bishop f3 play
f5 here I have six I take and defend my
rook so finally things are simplifying I
think I'm just winning a piece
had to play g5 I just want to make a
passer okay fifth place 18 points rough
Hall and clear first with 22 I mean
cuckoo Kiki let's play it's before again
we have a Sicilian a six a six is a line
that I play quite often but d3 g6 let's
play h4 I'll be aggressive
I can play h6 here yeah why not just
trying to disturb development what to do
Bishop b3 continue developing maybe g4e
Queen d2 first Queen d2 just trying to
be solid I was thinking that if I play
g4 black would have g5 now g4 is
threatening to drop the bishop black my
castle here counseling them I probably
go for f5 also should keep in mind he
five ideas this is just a bishop trap
pawns are oh that's not the bishop trap
forgot about that move as a blind spot
but okay things are still Pleasant I
think like c4 ideas this is kind of
tender
want to play e5 soon a five also
possible
I'll just castle that's a reasonable
move maybe I'll reroute the knight to f6
like Knight g4 it's a nice it's kind of
hole in blacks position it's true all
the pawns are still on the board
I've spaced on the Kings side Locke has
faced on the Queen side and we're castle
on the side that we have more space on
so it's actually hard to attack I think
for either of us maybe I'll start with a
move like a 3 or c3 c3 looks interesting
I don't want to play f5 and just give
away the e5 square again apologies for
the lag
I think I'm dropping frames what to do
no am i offline I'm still connected to
me chess
ah what do I do
I could stop and start now it just
reconnected that's really strange
I wonder if it's I wonder if it's like
connected to some Asian servers but it
should be set by default so I'm not
losing connection on me chess at six
well winning Kinect for play a 3 or p3
let's play Brooke here first so I have a
nice time advantage entirely sure what
my plan is
but so I'm just improving and playing
quickly have some nice B file d4 start
with Queenie - this is Bishop a6
do I sack yeah let's talk
defend enough to threatening stuff like
this if I can draw your OHS Bishop f1
always played this path fine actually
Queen c5 the threats that's okay okay
staying clean third place still some
catching up to do
playing for trucha okay I want to catch
up but again I have to remember that I'm
deserting Todd is going insane
it's play d4 I'll have a whatever we
call this this is what I play as black
it's like I'm playing against myself
no there's some f5 move at some points
there's also like the idea of just
playing positionally I think p3 sort of
this like b3 9 a 4 there should be 2
it's maybe one exceptions of the rule I
even though I have appallingly five I
would like to attack it is hard to
actually generate an attack as white at
least a sound attack maybe at some point
I can play a five though like g4 f5 okay
going for the attack it's a natural plan
yeah this actually kind of looks scary
for flack threatening f6 black doesn't
really want to take oh this looks really
nice
the only concern is that I'm a little
bit low on time but everything else is
nice so efficient of g7 f6 Bishop h8 and
then Queen h6 threatening rogue h3
just took a little bit extra time making
sure lock doesn't really have any
defense finding maiden to add Queen
takes you mean Queen takes h7 Queen take
it takes h7 did not quite work because
the kingdom couldn't escape back to g8
is this pre movable I think this is or
this is and this is a cream oof yeah
saving as much time as possible so I
beserk which means after this game I
should get five points and she catapult
me to 27 opponent playing the stall
gambit
sacrificing all the time so he doesn't
lose by checkmate
okay doctor turn mints
first place let's try and maintain the
cleanliness hello to Petrus giant giving
me a shout-out in the turn in chat
alright what to do let's play do I do
let's play d5 I'll try and play
something solid take with Knights c5
looks solid white house e4 84 and I have
six I'm not really trying to take too
much risk this game and like before
looks interesting as d3 is like
surprisingly weak in some lines like
Bishop a six-night d3 could be somewhat
troublesome for whites 95 if I could
take a knight c2
interesting mrs. Bishop f6 go play
Bishop f6 I was questioning the night
how half for pulling playing very
aggressively so I could take a lot of
forcing lines this probably calls for
some positional move a5
even still Bishop a 6g Bishop a6 kind of
looks attractive as I might go for the
line where I give up the bishop hair but
white White's Bishop which is supposed
to be a good piece is just stuck where
does the rook move rook here I have this
okay - I have 31
I should be it winning at least a pawn
there is Bishop f4 so the knight defends
a rook could trade everything let's
trade and win the a pawn attack defend
wanna play g5 at some point make c2
expected I losing connection again
apologies if I am yeah that's a good
move
let's play this okay great I got g5 in
going after this pawn or this pawn or
this pawn 3096 why provoked me into
playing it my rook is almost trapped
that's a good move no no let's not hang
a night I'm very low on time I'd move no
first move okay
that was a nice turn of events should be
enough time
I've shown this exact me to students
it's Queen D three mates it was good to
know that - because I was running low on
time back to tournaments always nice to
know the most efficient weight -
checkmate
all right first place let's go playing t
Tenten this calls for some more tea
playing a Tennyson gambit very similar
to like a reverse budapest this would be
a budapest if there is a pawn here
White's falling for like the mean trap
this is this is the whole point of the
Tennyson gambit just hoping black falls
for this trap Wow okay seven move
victory extending my lead I have to
prove my greatness 35 points 13 minutes
left and that's the first time ever
trapping someone with a Tennyson trap
should play that more often
next game playing ro TT
maybe I should just go for more traps
okay Stafford gambit declined should be
pleasant
what is this maybe this move I think
this is okay
threatening Knight g3 I'm temporarily
down the pawn but I have the bishop hair
I have activity I'm in first place what
to do maybe this move pinning the night
and also clearing way for a pawn of five
we could repeat let's not repeat
quantify being aggressive I think the
goal is to a attack eventually to play
rook e8 I want to bring the other up to
you it's just got all the pieces into
play
I'm just gonna leave the pawns as they
are not really trying to win back upon
in some way this is a gambit I have the
bishop hair have nice peace harmony have
a nice night
but I cannot be taken I don't think it's
interesting move Bishop g5 yeah taking
advantage of the pin I kind of want to
sack a queen it looks wrong but it looks
fun now there's no reason to I was
thinking about taking and then taking
but I mean this just looks a lot simpler
I have a g5 at some points it's about h6
first and then threatening g5 I kind of
forgot there there's three attackers on
only two defenders but it's not so bad
because I have bishop g6 if rook takes
e4 and yeah I'm rewarded for ignorance
but I'm also rewarded for just putting
pieces on reasonable squares maybe I
should have taken first now I can take
okay whether the odds that light gets
back ring mated it's closed
not sure what move I'm hoping for some
tactic its imagine Queen c4 and then
this and then let's say just queen a4 I
have Queenie one maybe the King should
be should the King be put it here I
think I might snot getting mated yet
let's play this move try and trade
Queens I still want the back ring mates
I should probably just like go after the
pawn
yeah the spin is gonna be unpleasant for
whites thinking rook out seven g5 like
g5 g4 is hard to stop it looks wrong so
I'm weakening the king but I mean what
does white to g4 I just take and g5 is a
straw that breaks the camel's back
okay extending my lead 39 points gained
a little bit of rating I don't think
I've gained more than like 10 points
this tournament playing chassis yawn
okay
I'm gonna stick with the same the same
repertory it's been working out in this
line I think I'll play I play whatever
this is called
it's a weird variation again apologies
for the lag I know it's lagging but my
phone's not moving maybe uh
maybe the lag is causing my opponent to
lag still not moving
you guys didn't miss much yeah so this
is um it's just a clean pond for a buck
trade I guess I do have like the the
word jet lag is in the stream title
that's a bit of a curse can't spell jet
lag without lag I take upon it's
probably too greedy put the bishop here
so this is just it's an interesting
situation I'll try and show how like one
single pawn is enough to like win the
game try and use the pond at some point
but I'm in really no rush
c6 will play a6 b5 I like my bishop the
bishop combined with these pawns are
that's pretty nice I love white - his
thing with the bishop in and f5 pawn
bishop d5 I win by tactics but the rook
here
just building up tension not entirely
sure what my plan is maybe Bishop g7 but
positions like this when you're up
material you just want to play like no
risk chess you just slowly simplify make
sure things are solid okay why trying to
pressure me if we trade all the rooks it
should be an easy win
so I want to play see for the problems
take stakes we could be one check so
let's start with this just improve the
rook I'll probably bring the king should
bring they came to the center there's h5
here mm probably not necessary c4 takes
takes play this move it looks timid but
idea is to get there look to this file
and then put the King on g5 you files on
the open file now my king can walk up
did I get a little bit careless guess I
kind of did see four takes maybe I
should take first yeah I think I got
careless but I don't think it's so bad
and like c-pawn should be quicker but
it's definitely getting a little bit
complicated
okay threatening this c5 pawn gives me
shelter hey this is gonna be the last
game so it's important that I don't mess
this up
White's trying to queen with check so it
would be a blunder it's a queen
actually after g7 I should start this
move
where's the quickest meats this looks
promising
okay well I think that that's the end of
the tournament pairings are closed I can
wait for confetti yeah overall I think I
had some interesting games have a few
messy games had a few like really quick
wins favorite game I mean some of them
what was that one with this Tennyson
gambit trap this was a feel-good game
then there is this game like mating with
a one second left and then then there is
a smothered mate game like this one
where I I think I deserved and I forgot
and everything just kind of worked out
so I'll probably put this on youtube
hopefully the lag isn't too bad it may
have oh there's confetti nice I thought
there's going to be a sound effect but
maybe not
it may have caught up the stream into
multiple streams especially if it just
died so I might have to do some editing
but I'll try and I'm gonna try and be
more active with YouTube so for you to
people watching in the future hope you
enjoyed that stay tuned for more videos
smash the like button and I'll see you
in the future